>> Pete: AND WE START AT THE
U.S. SOUTHERN BORDER TONIGHT.
AMERICA'S HOTTEST NEW
DESTINATION SEEMS TO BE DEL RIO,
TEXAS OR AS ILLEGALS MIGHT CAUSE
BIDENVILLE.
HAS A NICE RING TO IT POPULATION
8, 10, 12,000.
WHO KNOWS?
THE SITUATION ON THE BORDER IS
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL AS
SHOCKING FOOTAGE SHOWED 12,000
MOSTLY HAITIAN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CRAMMED UNDER A
BRIDGE IN SOUTH TEXAS LAST WEEK.
AND THEY ARE STILL THERE RIGHT
NOW.
THINGS ARE SO BAD IT'S NOT JUST
REPUBLICANS SOUNDING THE ALARM
AS OBAMA'S DHS SECRETARY JEH
JOHNSON, WELL, HE IS ALSO CRYING
UNCLE.
>> WE HAVE TO GET CONTROL OF OUR
BORDERS.
200,000 A MONTH IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
DHS JUST RELEASED THE NUMBERS
FOR AUGUST, IT'S 200,000.
AUGUST IS TYPICALLY A MONTH
WHERE IT'S VERY LOW.
AND THOSE KINDS OF NUMBERS AND
THE IMAGES YOU JUST SHOWED YOUR
AUDIENCE SAPS THE ABILITY.
IT OVERWHELMS THE ABILITY OF
THS, THE BORDER PATROL, ICE,.
>> Pete: OVERWHELMED.
UNABLE TO IGNORE THE CRISIS ANY
LONGER THE WHITE HOUSE SENT
CURRENT HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
DOWN TO TEXAS WITH A SHALL WE
SAY WEAK MESSAGE FOR THESE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> WE ARE VERY CONCERNED THE
HAITIANS WHO ARE TAKING THIS
IRREGULAR MIGRATION PATH ARE
RECEIVING FALSE INFORMATION THAT
THE BORDER IS OPEN OR THE
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS IS
AVAILABLE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
KNOWN THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO
COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS FALSE INFORMATION.
IF YOU COME TO THE UNITED STATES
ILLEGALLY, YOU WILL BE RETURNED.
>> Pete: UM-HUH.
WHERE IS THIS SO-CALLED FALSE
INFORMATION COMING FROM?
WHY DO TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGALS, REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY ARE COMING FROM, THINK THE
BORDER IS OPEN?
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE JOE BIDEN HAS
SPENT ALL THIS YEAR AND LAST
YEAR ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
ROLLING OUT THE BORDERLESS
WELCOME MAT OR SUSPENDING
DEPORTATION FLIGHTS TO HAITI
EARLIER THIS YEAR GAVE THIS
GROUP OF ILLEGALS ALL THE
ENCOURAGEMENT THEY NEEDED TO
RUSH THE BORDER.
AND, OF COURSE, THE MEDIA ON TOP
OF THE SITUATION.
PRESSING JEN PSAKI TODAY ON WHAT
IS CLEARLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
>> WE ARE ALLOWING AFGHANS TO
COME IN AFGHAN SUPPORTERS COME
IN AS WELL AS MEXICANS AND THEN
HAITIANS ARE NOW ALLOWED.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT, THE ISSUE
OF EQUITY AND FAIRNESS?
>> Pete: CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT?
LET'S PLAY BY THAT LEFT WING
GAME FOR A SECOND.
WHY ARE THEY TURNING AWAY THESE
BLACK PEOPLE?
ARE THEY NOT THE RIGHT COLOR TO
CROSS THE BORDER?
WHY DO SOME BLACK AND BROWN
ILLEGALS GET TO CLAIM ASYLUM AND
BE TREATED WITH COMPASSION BUT
OTHERS GET DEPORTED?
WHY DOES BIDENVILLE GET TARGETED
WITH DRACONIAN MEASURES LIKE
DEPORTATION?
THIS IS THE GROUP YOU GET TOUGH
ON?
POOR ILLEGALS YEARNING WHO LIVE
FREE.
BIDENVILLE IS THE LITERAL
DEPICTION OF THE HUDDLED MASSES,
YET, JOE TURNS THEM BACK?
SOUNDS PRETTY RACIST TO ME.
SURELY CAM RAD ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ WILL BE THERE TO
CRY FOR THEIR PLIGHT LIKE SHE
WAS AT THE DONNA FACILITY OR
MAYBE MAYOR JOE BIDEN WILL
DEPORT HER TOO.
THERE ARE NO RULES.
AND OTHERS ARE JUST ARBITRARY,
SO WHO KNOWS?
BUT, NO.
SHE WANTS TO TAX THE RICH LIKE
REALLY BAD.
SO, SHE IS SAFE.
EVERY OTHER DAY THE BORDER IS
OPEN BUT TODAY IT'S CLOSED FOR
BLACK HAITIANS IN BIDENVILLE.
WHAT IS THE STANDARD?
WHAT IS THE PLAN AT THE BORDER?
MAYBE THE PLAN IS NO PLAN?
THE ONLY THING JOE BIDEN IS
TRYING TO AVOID AT THE BORDER IS
BAD MEDIA COVERAGE.
AND HE IS EVEN BAD AT THAT.
MEANWHILE PATRIOTIC LAW
ENFORCEMENT BORDER AGENTS PUT IN
IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION
BABY-SITTING AT BIDENVILLE WHILE
THE MEXICAN CARTELS TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE.
YOU HEARD JEH JOHNSON SAY
200,000 ARE CROSSING THE BORDER
IN AUGUST?
WITH ALL THE HOLES BEING CREATED
ALONG THE BORDER, I'M SURE THE
NUMBER IS MUCH HIGHER.
AND WHERE WAS MAYOR JOE BIDEN
THIS WEEKEND?
WELL, HE WAS MAKING SURE THINGS
ARE ALL GOOD UP THERE IN
DELAWARE.
WHILE LICKING ICE CREAM CONES
AND MASKLESS BIKE RIDES.
HOW DARE HE AS CRISIS AFTER
CRISIS EXPLODES UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP.
OR NON-LEADERSHIP.
DON'T WORRY, VICE PRESIDENT
GIGGLE WAS ON THE CASE.
YOU WOULD FIGURE ROOT CAUSES
KAMALA WOULD BE POSTED UP IN
PORT-AU-PRINCE, FIGURING OUT THE
REAL PROBLEMS IN HAITI.
BUT, INSTEAD, SHE WAS WANDERING
AROUND THE 50-YARD LINE AT A
FOOTBALL GAME IN WASHINGTON,
D.C., FLIPPING COINS.
HEADS THE CITIZENS OF BIDENVILLE
STAY.
TAILS THEY GO.
SO IT'S OBVIOUS WE CAN'T COUNT
ON THE WHITE HOUSE TO FIX THIS
CRISIS.
BUT, LUCKILY, OUR DEMOCRAT LED
CONGRESS IS DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
THEY SPENT LAST WEEK BUILDING A
WALL, PUTTING THE NATIONAL GUARD
ON STAND BY AND GATHERING THE
ENTIRE NATIONAL MEDIA SO
EVERYONE COULD SEE WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
NOT ON THE BORDER.
BUT, INSTEAD, OUTSIDE THE U.S.
CAPITOL.
AS TEXAS IS LITERALLY OVERRUN
WITH ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, OURSELF
CENTERED LEADERS IN THE SWAMP
ARE ERECTING WALLS THAT
APPARENTLY WORK AND CALLING IN
THE NATIONAL GUARD OVER A TINY
PEACEFUL PROTEST AND, OF COURSE,
PREDICTABLY THE LEFT WING MEDIA
LAPPED IT ALL UP.
SEE, DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
PROTECTING YOU OR ME OR THE
BORDER OR OUR NATION.
THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT PROTECTING
THEMSELVES, THEIR POLITICAL
POSITION, AND THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY ARE IGNORING
THE BORDER.
IT DOESN'T AFFECT THEM EXCEPT
THEY HOPE IN THE FUTURE AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
SO THEY ARE FOCUSED ON SHOVING
INSTEAD ON SHOVING A
$3.5 TRILLION SOCIALIST SPENDING
BILL DOWN OUR THROAT.
FUNDAMENTAL LING CHANGING OUR
COUNTRY AND THE ECONOMY IN THE
PROCESS.
BARACK OBAMA TALKED ABOUT
FUNDAMENTAL TRANSFORMATION.
HE NEVER WOULD HAVE DREAMED OF A
BILL AS RICH AS THE
$3.5 TRILLION BILL THEY ARE
TRYING TO PASS.
THE BORDER, CRIME, COVID,
INFLATION, ALL DISTRACTION,
MAYOR JOE BIDEN VICE PRESIDENT
GIGGLES AND THEIR USE USELESS
DHS SECRETARY HAD BIGGER PLANS
AND THEY ARE DETERMINED TO PASS
3.5 TRILLION OF THEM.
YOUR SAFETY A